[Musique]
joyeuses pâques tous nos amis bonjour
aux sports voici notre surprise
rémi toto et fanfan qui viennent passer
quelques jours chez nicolas et
pimprenelle au le seul en avant le
sursaut descendons je mets deux petites
attentions les neveux ne vous bousculez
pas à tout de suite
patron bonsoir les enfants joyeuses
pâques sur la jeune femme il avait
trouvé une surface où le hors jeu qui
frappe à l'afl
elles aideront voir les enfants qui peut
me dire à cette heure
quelle surprise
[Musique]
merci qu est ce que tu es gentil que les
avons ramené moi aussi je suis content
de les revoir ses petits
d'accord d'accord je le l'hôte rémi toto
et fanfan ont apporté quelque chose que
je ne sais pas nous avons rencontré les
cloches pour le spl elles nous ont remis
ces pauses pour tous les jours
[Musique]
temmar de mignot plus du canada en ski
sont jolies il faut pas la gâcher tout
chiffrage et ses fauves en touche pas
rémy il ne faut pas les effrayer ses
petits canards ne vous connaissent pas
encore
tu aimais petit canard voici de l'eau et
du sable il aime beaucoup le sable petit
canal vient est-ce qu'il est de route
c'est lui la tiens record un peu de ça
vient petit à bord qui sont amusants
mais oui ils bossent les petits canards
se couche tôt le soir à l'eau au dodo
petit âne à mes petits neveux
brooks gros 1 2
oui on change et une lune ou de vrais
visages à vous à présent un peu 3
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
je suis bien content ils sont vraiment
très gentils
nos deux petits amis et tes neveux mon
cher nounours de vrai petit ange potro
j'ai voulu vous aussi les petits enfants
faites nous plaisir et aller sagement
vous coucher tu es prêt nounours lui
paquereau je suis preuve alors hein
2 3 en route
bonne nuit à demain
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]